[Music]
the brochure asked can a belligerent
foreign policy lead to stability in the
world like we've never tried that before
in fact the world is in chaos precisely
because of a belligerent foreign policy
and sometimes the belligerents are mad
like Donald Trump bad like Tony Blair
imbecilic like George W Bush but they
were all exponent so of and
practitioners of a belligerent foreign
policy and the results are there for all
to see the question seems premise on the
assumption that we have had a non
belligerent foreign policy at any point
in modern history in fact since the
United States was born it has been at
war all but one year all but one year in
its entire lifetime and the last time
Britain had no soldiers fighting abroad
and only briefly was in 1779 so we have
had not just a lifetime of but centuries
of foreign policy belligerents and it
doesn't flow from any psychopathic
character necessarily although some like
Richard Nixon in his belligerent foreign
policy was undoubtedly psychopathic like
his foreign policy guru seems to have
been the guru to many including the
aforementioned Tony Blair Henry
Kissinger were undoubtedly psychopathic
but it doesn't necessarily require that
it requires a view of the world that the
rich and powerful
the right to dictate to the less rich
and less powerful the the people who can
do if you can conquer other people's
countries in the past or conquer their
economic reality if not their territory
as happens more often nowadays if you
can you do and that's why we have chaos
and violence and the threat of truly
unbelievable levels of violence in front
of us today you asked Marianne about
Trump and his foreign policy let's
review it
Trump has unilaterally withdrawn from
the Iran nuclear deal signed Salomon
binding by his predecessor and the
prominent 5+1 and the Islamic Republic
of Iran and impeccably I'm using the
words of the IAEA impeccably observed by
Iran Trump has unilaterally withdrawn
from it begun a raft of ever deep and
punishing economic sanctions against
Iran and yesterday a major terrorist
atrocity was carried out by Saudi
sponsored which means American sponsored
terrorists in I was in Iran which killed
26 people now not just soldiers
but old soldiers paraplegic soldiers
members of the public in the crowd and
journalists covering the event we are
headed potentially to cataclysmic
conflict again in the Middle East what
could possibly go wrong
Iran will undoubtedly respond
extremely violently against Saudi Arabia
at any minute certainly not long-delayed
that will be get a response and so the
spiral towards war will twist Pompeo the
US Secretary of State the former head of
the CIO CIA this week threatened actions
against Venezuela they've already got
sanctions almost uncountable number of
them now it's us actions against
Venezuela that we can expect in the next
few days and the elephant in the room
the morass of the Syrian war some of you
know me from my stand against the Iraq
war I'm here to tell you that the
involvement of Western countries in the
Syrian war is the worst thing we have
ever done ie worse than Libya worse than
Iraq our belligerent foreign policy of
arming financing propagandizing for Isis
al Qaeda and the alphabet soup of
Islamist fanaticism in Syria is the
worst thing that we have ever done and
notwithstanding that the war is almost
over we may very well be about to double
down to double our bets on the
catastrophic conflict in Syria
so can a belligerent foreign policy
bring about peace and stability in the
world not bloody likely
[Applause]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you